il est trop vieux il est malade il va
quitter son poste l'année prochaine
semble s'inquiéter la presse américaine
et anglaise
vous pensez à jobs hayden et ben non
elle est jaune on parle bien de vladimir
poutine vladimir poutine prévoit de
démissionner l'année prochaine alors
qu'en russie
des spéculations circulent sur le fait
que le président de longue date pourrait
être atteint de la maladie de parkinson
lit-on dans un rapport publié jeudi
l'article précise que vladimir poutine
agonise déjà et va quitter le pouvoir en
janvier prochain nouvel an nouveau
président
les observateurs qui ont examiné les
images récentes de poutine ont noté que
ses jambes semblaient être en mouvement
constant et qu'il semblait souffrir en
s'agrippant à l'accoudoir d'une chaise
ses doigts semble également se
contracter lorsqu'il tient un stylo et
saisi une passe qui pourrait contenir un
cocktails d'analgésiques
le tort du scoop se nomme valérie
solovey ex professeur des relations
publiques à la prestigieuse université
des relations internationales de moscou
celui qui se vante sur facebook de sa
capacité à donner son temps pau à
l'actualité internationale où on n'est
pas son premier pronostic
poutine est il sur le point de
démissionner selon un expert du kremlin
le président russe pourrait démissionner
pour raisons de santé
mais puisque en 2016 ça n'a pas marché
le professeur récidive en 2017
il ne peut y avoir de deuxième poutine
la russie envisage un avenir sans
vladimir des sources affirmant qu'il
prévoit de démissionner li indépendantes
pourraient révéler une image
d'incertitude intense au coeur du
pouvoir
la porte parole du kremlin lui ne
s'inquiète pas du départ imminent de son
chef
il n'y a rien à commenter ici c'est une
absurdité complète
je voudrais alors précisé tout va bien
chez le président il est en bonne santé
alors sans aucun doute il ne prévoit pas
démissionner c'est ça non un moment de
l'histoire où les reines des états unis
s'apprêtaient choirat un homme qui
semble ne pas se souvenir du prénom de
son adversaire du poste auquel il
prétend et qui confond les prénoms de
ses petits-enfants et les plus que temps
de s'inquiéter de la façon dont vladimir
poutine qui en son stylo